almost four years ago on this show we
talked to a former georgia state
representative called la don
jones about black lives matter jones is
a strong supporter of blm so not
surprisingly she was well practiced in
the now highly familiar tactic
of denouncing everything she doesn't
like is racist and we knew that going
into the interview
what was surprising was to hear ladon
jones go after the beloved children's
book author dr
seuss she called dr seuss a bigot here's
the exchange from 2017.
i actually had to once i heard the story
pull out our dr seuss books that are on
my children's bookshelf
and take a closer look at them so i can
see exactly what it was that was the
complaint
and as is what was it many of us what
was it
i mean actually i've been obviously
speaking tongue-in-cheek because this is
like literally demented but since you
said that you checked
dr seuss for racism what did you find
where were the racist parts
so you look at many of the drawings and
you have to put it in the context
of the times that many of these books
were written and
you can see that there are some very
stereotypical drawings of asian
americans
dr seuss was known for some very
stereotypical blackface drawings prior
to the books that most of us are
familiar with
now at the time what you just heard
seemed incomprehensible in fact as we
noted
kind of demented say what you will about
dr seuss maybe you think his drawings
are primitive maybe some of his dog rule
doesn't actually rhyme
fair but dr seuss was not a racist
dr seuss was a preachy liberal he was an
evangelist against bigotry he wrote an
entire shelf of books against
racism and not in a subtle way they were
clearly explicitly
against racism that was the whole point
of writing them
to teach children not to be racist now
as it happens
today is dr seuss's birthday born ted
geisel in springfield massachusetts he
would be 117 years old
were he alive today and thank god he
isn't because he would be wounded and
confused
every year on dr seuss's birthday the
president whomever he is at the time
makes a proclamation in support of
something called read across america day
that's designed
to encourage kids to read books and
every year the president
mentions dr seuss because again it's his
birthday that's the whole point of it
but not this year joe biden omitted dr
seuss from this year's proclamation why
because dr
seuss is now considered a racist so what
seemed like total lunacy less than four
years ago is now the official position
of the white house
now the shocking thing about this is not
that it happened academic
revolutionaries have been attacking
traditional children's books for decades
a few years ago some [ __ ] at boston
university produced so-called research
on
curious george's undercurrent of white
dominance quote
the series celebration of the oppression
of an abducted monkey parallels the
oppression of black americans
and so on you won't be surprised to
learn that that girl now works for bill
de blasio in new york of course she does
what's surprising is how calculated all
this is
now conservatives will be tempted to
chalk up the attacks on dr seuss to the
usual canceled culture gone mad
look how hysterical and stupid the
professional left is
they're even calling dr seuss racist
and you've seen people say that on
social media today
but it's totally missing the point
canceling dr
seuss isn't stupid it's intentional
they're banning dr seuss not because he
was a racist
but precisely because he wasn't
in 1961 dr seuss wrote a story called
the sneeches
martin luther king's march on washington
was still two years away but dr seuss
story
captured its essence in case you haven't
already read it to your kids 50 times
and know it by heart here's the plot
there's a group of furry pear-shaped
animals called sneeches who live on what
looks like a far away planet
now if that sounds weird to you be aware
that dr seuss rarely drew people
probably because he didn't want to
elevate
one kind of person over any other kind
of person
he wasn't a racist in any case there are
two groups of sneetches in the story
those with star-shaped designs on their
stomachs and those without
there's no real difference between the
two groups but the sneetches don't know
that
they're convinced that stars are all
important
so they spend the entire story jockeying
for position
based on their relative starness at
various points in the story stars on the
stomach are deemed socially favorable
at others they're considered a mark of
disgrace and the stitches run around
frantically trying to keep up with the
changing demands of star
fashion until they realize in the
uplifting final pages of the story
that none of it matters underneath the
stars they're all the same
they're all sneetches who cares who's
got a star
what matters isn't the group you come
from what matters
is you even a five-year-old gets the
point of the story
at the deepest level it doesn't matter
what we look like because underneath it
all we're all the same
we're all human beings we're in this
together
all that outward appearance stuff is
pointless it just makes people hate each
other
and it makes us look ridiculous if
there's a more powerful statement on the
universal brotherhood of man it's
probably not in the children's section
of the bookstore
for 60 years american children have read
the sneetches and books like it
and that's one of the reasons we have
the country we have today
in which most americans those who don't
work at the universities or for the joe
biden administration
accept martin luther king's most famous
precept that what matters is the content
of our characters
not the color of our skins the sneetches
affirm this
the story is a plea for colorblindness
and
that's why the forces of wokeness hate
it and dr
seuss when the people in charge cancel
dr
seuss what they're really trying to
eliminate is a very specific kind of
mid-century american culture
a culture that championed meritocracy
and colorblindness
and the superiority of individual
achievement over tribal identity
these were once called liberal values
modern liberals don't want to be
reminded that they once believed any of
this
if your kids are allowed to read dr
seuss they will know this was a
different country not so long ago
a place where people tried hard not to
hate each other
a place where the population was
encouraged begged by its leaders to
reject identity politics
in favor of universal values and the
things that connect us all
dr seuss was never a major literary
figure but his memory matters more than
it
ever has the battle over dr seuss
what he stood for the battle over what
it means to be racist
will have consequences that extend for
generations
and if we lose that battle america is
lost